oh yeah screen junkies in full effect
so Adam Sandler and his gang of
40-somethings are farting their way back
into theaters this weekend
with grownups too so that got me
thinking how do we feel about the
Sandman I hit the streets of Hollywood
to take the temperature on Adam Sandler
I talked to the people and here's what
they had to say are you guys Adam
Sandler fans yeah totally what's your
favorite Adam Sandler movie I really
like clicked clicked
I like Milly Madison grownups happy
gilmore 50 first dates 51 dates 51 dates
that's a great Adam Sandler film who was
the one who do about Christmas crazy
nights yes that was one of them that was
actually about Hanukkah
well Hanukkah and Christmas is
synonymous I could introduce you to a
lot of people who would disagree with
you
what do you say to people who say Adam
Sandler isn't funny anymore they're
Canadian
he's funny you he's still funny I'd say
just as humors change and a perfect
example as a movie click very
family-oriented a little less raunchy
have you seen Jack and Jill yeah when he
played his sister what'd you think of
that it was something crazy that white
people think of white people think what
about Eddie Murphy playing his whole
family it was totally different
what about recent movies like Jack and
Jill you don't think it was too
ridiculous him playing both of those
characters no I think he did pulled it
off very well yeah it shows how complex
he is an actor gyda I can't stand you
being here Oh Jack and Jill so like can
you talk like that
yeah jail out of Nam man isn't like that
yeah exactly
I'm gonna show you a clip from Jack and
Jill and I want you to tell me what you
think of it yeah I can't here I'm trying
to step on the phone well get off the
phone you psycho how does this look to
you
it looks pretty funny really are you
looking forward to grown-ups - yes look
into that camera and say yo I'm getting
my grown ups on hey I'm getting my grown
ups on I guess the people still like
Sandler so those critics apparently you
could take those reviews and wipe your
butts with them grown-ups 2 is actually
Adam Sandler's first sequel nope there's
no Little Nicky - that got me thinking
about comedy sequels a lot of them
really suck so here are the top 5 worst
comedy sequels of all time number 5
Blues Brothers 2000 fun fact Blues
Brothers 2000 was made in 1998 what they
replaced John Belushi with John Goodman
it's just not the same they replaced Dan
Aykroyd with old Dan Aykroyd this movie
had none of the rebel outlaw spirit of
the first one there's an orphan kid
blues brother aw shucks
number 4 Little Fockers Robert De Niro
is one of the all-time greats Raging
Bull Goodfellas Casino Mean Streets taxi
driver but prolonged exposure to Ben
Stiller has led to exchanges like this
you'll receive Little Fockers as much
juicy Raging Bull not taxi driver put
the Queen is he play in it no now will
Queen Latifah you're talking about taxi
Martin Scorsese's taxi driver the horror
number 3
weekend at Bernie's - what they're still
playing with that corpse how is it not
stinking and falling apart playing with
a corpse for one 90-minute movie kind of
fun playing with a course for to
90-minute movies that's a sick new level
of depravity disgusting number 2 a tie
between hangover 2 & 3 or as I like to
call them the Matrix sequels of comedy
follow the Wolfpack as they get more and
more underwhelming here's the thing you
start in Vegas then you did the same
exact movie in Bangkok for part 3
weren't they either supposed to go to
space or hell you drop the ball that was
a layup and you're number one dumb and
Dumberer you know it's a bad sign when
no one associated with the first film
wants to come anywhere near the sequel
no Jim Carrey no Jeff Daniels not even a
single Farrelly brother but they decide
to make it anyway morons
that's my list what do you think the
worst comedy sequel of all time is leave
an answer below tell us why and the best
answer gets a $25 gift card from Best
Buy
courtesy of our sponsor cinema now from
Best Buy I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
bye-bye